Knowing they were people once
you don't tell anyone about your condition
we're trying to keep you alive you're
not immune from being ripped apart
Frank we will never have friends
because there are no friends to be had
just because life stopped for you
doesn't mean it has to stop for me
there's no halfway with this
we finished what we started
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. This will be my last of us episode 2trailer video they just released there's a bunch
of Easter eggs and references to the game a lot
of the scenes are directly taken from different
parts of the game so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel not doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to subscribe
to get them all careful for spoilers from episode
one if you haven't seen it yet just starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage this
covers the next part of their story in a couple of
scenes from way later episodes too but it's mostly
the next part of their story and pretty much like
the next leg of the game that they cover on their
way to Bill and franks is they first make their
way into the outer parts of Boston outside the
regular quarantine Zone in one small change during
episode 1 during their escape when Joel winds up
killing the guard Ellie doesn't immediately tell
him in the episode that she's the key to finding
the vaccine after it's discovered she's infected
but hasn't turned yet in the chaos after he kills
the guard they just take off through the fence
into the business district you start hearing the
cries of the other infected and then the military
Sirens they only took that about halfway like he
learned she's in affected but hasn't completed
the thought like oh wait a minute she's infected
but hasn't turned that means that she's immune
I guess because they're saving that for episode
two as they start to talk more to each other and
learn more about each other but the whole idea
is that when he killed the Guardia that PTSD
flashed back to his daughter being killed and
just went full dad but like he went full Mando
on the guard while that was happening they also
explained that Ellie also gets super excited by
it too like it activates something inside her
like the survival Instinct and she's excited at
the thought of someone killing someone else for
her like going full dad mode for her but she's
also kind of excited to see this guard punished
for what she did to her so it's part of the idea
that these two people belong together like they
feed off of each other's energy but it's actually
Tess who's thinking clear in the aftermath who
tells them that they both need to get the hell
out of their escape to the outer zone is the
military siren start blaring and the infected
cry out in the distance letting you know that
there's danger coming for them from all sides
like part of the ideas that the military will
learn that they killed the guard and come for them
the area that they're heading to is just an next
part of the game like it's right out of the game
it's basically the Boston business district and
they find out pretty quickly where those screams
were coming from they start running into a bunch
more infected during various stages like Runners
stalkers full-blown clickers that you see in the
trailer the first one that they show you in the
trailer I don't know if this is meant to be linear
the way they appear during the episode but this
one seems more like a stalker like the show's just
slowly revealing them in successive stages during
episode one we saw a runner in the flashbacks
that's what the old lady was when she started
chowing down on the rest of her family and I think
the early part of this episode is meant to be more
of a literal tutorial for Ellie who's never really
been beyond the walls of the quarantine Zone this
way this up close and personal with the infected
she knows all about them like she understands
what's going on with the infection and what kinds
of infected there are and how dangerous they are
but the idea is that she's never been faced with
killing someone up close like she was with Joel
protecting her killing the guard she's never been
this up close with them killing infected so it's
a lot of Joel trying to teach her on the Fly and
keep her safe still being in full dad mode as
they encounter all these new types of infected
but during the trailer you can kind of see as they
sort of jump back and forth and things slow down a
little bit Joel's senses start coming back to
him he's still thinking of Ellie like another
job he doesn't completely like her that much at
this point she just means to an end so we can get
one step closer to helping his brother Tommy in
Wyoming which we also see in the trailer all these
scenes in the snow of him talking to Tommy that's
from like way later episodes remember Wyoming
other side of the United States so it's after
they've been traveling for a good long while but
part of the idea with Tommy is that he used to be
part of the fireflies that's kind of why he hated
the Firefly so much why he didn't like Marlene
because he blamed them for Tommy turning against
him or he thinks that Tommy turned against him
but part of the idea like you see scenes in the
trailer where Tommy's talking to him like look
your life might be messed up mine doesn't have
to be messed up the whole idea is that Tommy's
settlement isn't part of the quarantine zones
like it's another Rogue group but it's actually a
more positive one like they're actually living a
fairly decent existence so it's just meant to be
a very positive example of what Society could be
in the apocalypse like oh we could actually live a
pretty decent life like their Town functions like
a pretty normal town as normal as you could be in
this kind of Apocalypse so when Joel encounters
Tommy again Tommy's sort of done like a big 180
like he's not as militant anymore he seems way
more well adjusted way happier he's gotten married
so in the way that Tommy always relied on Joel
like they joked about that during episode one of
the flashbacks like Tommy's depending on me Joel
thinks that he's going to die if he doesn't
get supplies to Tommy but really it's kind of
the other way around Tommy's the person who winds
up helping Joel emotionally and just practically
like he helps them survive literally like in a
practical way but he's also trying to help him
emotionally like look you could actually lead a
pretty decent life so Tommy's settlement becomes a
much bigger thing especially later in the game and
during the second game but at least in the early
part of the story like early part of episode two
when things are still super crazy for them it's
actually Tess who's thinking more about Ellie's
Grand role and everything and is this big call to
action for Joel like look you need to come to your
senses this girl means so much to humanity but at
least at this point Joel doesn't want to hear any
of that like he doesn't care at all that's why
he's telling La look you're just another job to
me we can keep our histories to ourselves but he
also still wants to protect her so that's why he's
telling her look you need to keep your condition
quote unquote to yourself mostly because of the
people that they encounter would want to take her
or do something with her one of the other trailers
you probably detected in the trailer footage here
because it has footage from a bunch of different
episodes is that they're not wearing any gas masks
like they do in the game when they travel to
different areas and that's because apparently
they're not doing the spores from the games like
The Walking Dead has zombies you kill them by
killing their brains you can do something similar
with the infected during the last of us but during
the last of us there are obviously many different
types of infected during different stages that
become successively more powerful and harder to
kill with different abilities but also on top of
that at least during the game when you kill them
their bodies give off sports that can continue to
infect you which is why you need to wear a gas
mask most of the time the funny thing because I
was see Pedro Pascal is the Mandalorian the whole
thing is that he wears a helmet for pretty much
the entire series is that during the last of us
they didn't want to have the characters wearing
things over their faces covering their faces the
entire time so they just elected not to do the
spores it's funny the way that some series will do
that like no no we need to see these actors faces
we can't cover their faces the whole time but then
you get to a series like the Mandalorian they're
like no we can cover his face the whole time it
makes sense it's totally fine but the big goal in
episode 2 originally in the game was to reach a
rendezvous point with the fireflies in this edge
of the city and in the game those fireflies were
the ones that were going to take Ellie the rest
of the way across the United States but they kind
of combined that with the end of episode one where
he's dealing with Marlene in all the fireflies
are already dead at that point she's like look
we only have you you need to take her the rest
of the way we'll give you all these supplies if
you complete the job please don't mess it up so
all that back and forth that he has arguing about
how he doesn't have time for it he doesn't want
to have anything to do with Ellie it's something
that happens a little bit later in the game after
they reach this area in the Boston District so I
think part of the idea in episode two they're
just trying to to make it through the rest of
the way the city out of the city to get to where
Bill and Frank are while they're intercutting all
these scenes we see more flashbacks of Ellie with
Riley's character played by storm Reed Riley was
another survivor of the Ellie befriended became
her best friend before she met Joel most of their
story was told during The Last of Us Left Behind
game DLC and it's all meant to be taking place
in the past so when the present day the show
picks up like when Ellie is beating Joel for
the first time Riley has already succumbed to the
infection and died and I think they're just using
it as Ellie's version of the big flashback that
Joel got at the beginning of episode one showing
you what her life was like up to this point
and how she came to be in this situation and
found out that she was immune because of doing
more flashbacks of her character that might be
where we see Ashley Johnson's Cameo scene because
we're basically seeing Ellie be born like she's
playing Ellie's mother during the series then
we meet Bill and Frank in the trailer this could
be from episode two it could be from episode 3
because episode 2 is a little bit shorter than
episode one they might end with them finishing
the journey just out of Boston before they find
Bill and Frank bill is played by Ron Swanson
himself Nick Offerman people already made a video
game meme of his character doing the Ron Swanson
move from Parks and Rec so it is perfect casting
Frank is played by Murray Bartlett they're a
couple living by themselves outside the quarantine
Zone near Boston and helped Joel and Ellie get
the truck that you see them driving in later in
the trailers the truck that he uses to literally
drive her across the United States they're not
meant to be super best friends or anything like
that but build new tests and it's just surprised
that she and Joel would undertake a mission like
Ellie because it's so dangerous and he helps them
find the rest of the parts of the car that they
need across the town that they live in the town
that they're in is Lincoln but part of the idea is
that they're infected all over the place so it's
easier said than done the reason why you see the
car crashing through here is because they have to
make a break for it when they get the car because
the battery has such a low charge they need to get
the car started and going so that the alternator
for the car will recharge the battery and they'll
be able to make it the rest the way one of the
other interesting things about Bill is the reason
why he's being able to survive for for so long
outside the quarantine zones is because of the
clever way he set up his defenses he's actually
using a lot of the infected as natural barriers
between him and other Interlopers like other
dangerous survivors in the military like you see
during the trailer it seems like Joel and Ellie
wind up in one of his traps the joke bill has in
the trailer with Frank about them never having
any friends is both a reference to their current
situation in Lincoln but also their encounter
with Ellie and Joel like they don't become good
friends or anything like that but they do become
slightly better friends and Bill is correct that
they are the only survivors living in Lincoln at
the moment so practically speaking it's going to
be hard for them to make new friends when there
are no people to actually make friends with the
scene with Melanie lynskey pulling the gun on Joel
is from a much later episode there's footage of a
bunch of future episodes later in this she's meant
to be a brand new character who wasn't from the
games who's a leader of a non-military rogue group
in Kansas so I think the idea is they encounter
them much later in their journey and I believe
that's where a lot of this footage is coming from
with a crowd cheering in the street all these
other soldiers wearing different types of armor
these two kids are brothers from the game that
Joel and Ellie wind up encountering relatively
early on after they find Bill and Frank and get
the car but before they reach Tommy's place in
Wyoming it is just as tragic as you would expect
but is there any Easter eggs or references in the
trailer that I didn't talk about in the video that
you spotted just write them Below in the comments
the other big news is tonight we're going to get
the brand new Mandalorian season 3 trailer more
Pedro Pascal and grogu of course I'll do a video
for that as soon as they release it it'll be in
a couple hours so make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that there's
a bunch of really big stuff coming up everyone
click here for that Mandalorian season 3 trailer
video I'll update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for my full Last of Us episode one
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!